get your stinky neck out my face get
yours you're not even invited who do you
know yeah who do you know here do you
actually know her apart from me yeah
boys girls is that time again
we're back we are back and you know how
we just go straight into the juicy stuff
and the question of the week was when
was the moment you realized that you
were the problem
and as per usual do you see I can
imagine very juicy it's the moment you
realize
okay yeah okay this is some
introspective stuff I love this all
right okay
when I told him I cheated he started
sobbing and asked what can I do to make
you stop oh
what can I do to make you stop I'm
crying no no no no no no stop no
cheating on me
I don't want to break up just please
stop cheating I can't live without you
don't cheat on me please please that's
what I'm asking I promise you now if you
had I could I I couldn't ask Nicole
Scherzinger to stop cheating on me I
couldn't ask Rihanna to stop cheating on
me Nicole sure Zinger what a throw yeah
she was the baddest one time she was the
Baddie of baddies
um bro I'm not asking anyone to please
stop cheating on me stop cry whilst
you're crying your eyes out stop and she
was like wow I'm a bit I am the problem
I'm actually a [__] I confessed to
cheating he said how could or is it how
can I make you stop how can I make you
stop what can I do to make you stop
be a man
yeah yeah that simple be strong and
brave yeah some do do actually how about
you do anything how about that just do
anything women know how to make guys for
Less Than Dirt oh Rago yeah Less Than
Dirt Rago do anything Roman inch
no
see that that is there's only so far we
can go yeah yeah literally yeah yeah let
me not talk
when my therapist asked me do I actually
like men or just like to manipulate them
oh that'll make you think about yourself
oh do you actually like Gallery do you
just love manipulating them
yeah I couldn't be faced with that
question yeah that's that's that's
that's this is why I'm not sure therapy
is for me because I'm like who do you
think you're talking to I will box you
yeah yeah I will smack your face bro
I'll smack your face with my heart right
now
then what yeah then what who's
manipulating who
do you just like to manipulate them wow
swear did I pay you to make opinions
yeah don't speak to me yeah first of all
don't speak to me yeah yeah I don't need
that confrontation
when two guys were fighting over me at
my friend's wedding and my boyfriend was
asleep upstairs
you just let it just sat back and let it
happen
my boyfriend zebra says and two next men
are fighting over fighting over me at my
friends and that's someone else's
wedding someone else's wedding I should
just start eating popcorn just watching
it yeah you might fight for me fight for
me for me I have a man but fight for me
also why is he asleep upstairs this is a
wedding or not I mean I'm assuming Hotel
actually yeah yeah I thought he was just
asleep yeah yeah Hotel team mad she
walked in on me with two girls again
after I previously cried and begged for
forgiveness absolute scenes
she walked in on me with two girls again
after I'd previously cried and begged
for her forgiveness
absolute scenes scenes bro
how many threesomes this guy happened
what do you mean again again
after I cried and begged for forgiveness
why why did you beg for forgiveness
because you knew you were going to do it
again ah yeah Amanda I'm just I actually
saw it um I'm actually gonna spin the
format today okay because this is so
incredibly relevant I'm gonna do a trash
news in between your questions it got
sent to me nine times today you must
have been saying it yeah yeah yeah you
know which one I'm on about maybe it is
maybe yeah woman nurse cheating husband
back to health after car accident then
he cheated again
fam Katie certain that I can't pronounce
from North Carolina revealed on Tick
Tock cause she revealed on Tick Tock
first of all course she revealed it on
Tick Tock they all do get a life
that she had nursed her cheating husband
actually cool first of all do we know
this is factual now that I'm just
reading it I'm like skeptical she said
this on Tick Tock right after she'd
nursed her cheating husband back to
health following a near fatal car
accident early last year worried she had
caused his crash by distracting him on
the phone Katie checked her husband's
phone to find him cheating on her with
several women through texts social media
and dating profiles
after months of nursing him back to
health he used his Newfound strength to
continue cheating on Katie when you
found strength you found strength wow
needless to say ke is currently filing
for divorce and potentially will be in
court to settle the couple's belongings
bro the new found strength that is wild
that's so out of pocket don't put words
in my mouth yeah yeah those attitudes
yeah yeah you don't know the details you
don't but they said that she was looking
through his phone while he was driving
um
that's what he said right she looked at
his phone because she said she felt
guilty for potentially causing the
accident so he must have been driving
look through his phone and she was
seeing stuff
arguments and he just he's trying to
concentrate swerved and then he died and
she's like wow wow
I'm sorry I was a DMV over here what's
the DM here and there it's life this is
me and you this is our lives Jesus I
nearly lost you I can't lose you again
sorry I'm [__] sorry let me heal I
forgive you yeah yeah let's heal up and
he said gang gang man found the strength
to walk from the Zimmer from the Zimmer
and just starting yeah I'm back I'm back
just a new selfie
I'm back ain't really Lee but I'm back
I'm back I'm back
when was the moment you realized you
were the problem
I didn't know which girl was pregnant
with my child
man was just slinging and didn't really
know
unless it was a case of this is I'm so
confused by that statement yeah I didn't
know which girl was pregnant with my
child so we were either talking about
Jazzy's
um or what
yeah it must be Jazzy's so why are you
the problem
that's a dumb one have you ever seen
that in this that's a dumb one
that's fun to me as well when I jumped
when I jumped on his back when he tried
to reach for my phone he didn't need to
see what was on there
listen to me there listen to me
the day the day
my wife's phone is here yeah and the
bowl of bananas is here
and I just go to and she jumps on my
back get off my phone don't touch my
phone oh
oh
yeah yeah
sit down yeah
sit down I I would the thing is though
you have to still reach for the banana
even when she's on your bike you'll be
like what are you doing
swear she's still on your back yeah
she's like slowly loses
yeah facts I wouldn't even check
that is such a power move yeah is that
you actually gently pick up the phone
give it don't even look at it give it to
her and like leave on your way yeah on
your way I didn't need to see what's on
there he's a [__] if he didn't react to
that oh 100 100 Telltale
when I unfollowed my ex on Spotify
yeah that's it come on that is pathetic
when I saw no pictures of me on his
phone
you you know you're the problem you
don't need to be seeing extra of you he
sees you enough yeah yeah I see you
enough yeah I don't want to reminisce
yeah you're here why do I need to
pictures of for fun I look at pictures
to enjoy life to remember what was what
was
it yeah not what is yeah you are right
now yeah yeah yeah meaty I don't need to
be reminded of you when I got punched
and they shook the hands of the puncher
wow
that's what took me when I got punched
and they shook the hands of the punch
that's funny that's funny that's what he
does money I cried when he didn't reply
to me not knowing I was the one that
didn't reply to him
you [__] you stupid little [__]
oh Christ when he did it reply to me wow
oh
woman replied ahead sometimes bad times
everybody had a lot why is he not
responding yeah why is he airing me
blood
blood when I followed him from party to
party hoping he could see the hickey
that someone else gave me
no that's not a thing I followed him
from party to party
wow
that's something that next man gave me
to see jealousy to see firework would
rile up this ain't Euphoria relax
yourself man bro relax yourself at the
neck at the second pile I've been like
big man no one cares about your moldy
net yeah facts get your stinky neck out
my face get yours you're not even
invited who did you know yeah who'd you
know here if you actually know her apart
from me yeah
get out of your swollen veins bro
nonsense Butters yeah
when I had a sneaky link come and pick
me up whilst I was on a date with my ex
the [__] when I had a sneaky link come
and pick me up whilst I was on a date
with my ex
that means she's got a current
she's got a Mane that she might have a
main exit can still be X
um yeah yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
she's got a current she's got X and he's
got a size yeah but why why did she have
a current why in order to just because
she's your ex doesn't mean you have a
parent true but I mean yeah yeah but he
yeah she might have a currently the way
she's moving yeah and she's on a date
with her ex and then a link picked her
up first of all I don't care if I'm your
ex or not if you're on a date with me on
a date with me Rags and the next man is
not picking you up and next man is not
picking you up where are you man going
we've just had the day together where
are you two going he's not your Uber
he's not your bolt where are you going
literally where are you going I would
lose my mind I promise you I would lose
my mind I couldn't take that level of
audacity
anyway this has been fun this has been
fun
um Jerome said to pick me up I'm gone
who I'm I'll be dropping you home yes
you can't
that is so fast that's such a flex and I
hate it that's so difficult because you
can't you can't do anything you can't or
you could just complain and the more you
can play the worse it gets this is why I
left yeah this is why he's taking me
home look at you begging begging like a
[__] look at you
she could have a woman stand up whilst
I'm sitting on the table saying look at
you look at you just looking when you
wonder why next man are picking me up
I might go to jail without it yeah of
course
look at you oh God anyway
um when was the moment you realized you
were the problem I was at awake chatting
to Four Guys realizing I'd slept with
them all including the deceased
Jesus Christ this is mad
that 99 of these are women
yeah so all I'm hearing
is that women are finding acknowledged
that they're the problem problem yeah
but in in secret in secret under the
guise of an anonymity yeah under the
guise of anonymity they are allowing
everyone to find out that they know that
they're they're I know I'm the problem I
know the problem I'm not gonna tell
anyone else but I do know I am the
problem all guys are just in denial
refuse to admit that the problem
interesting I know they're going to spin
with it that's why I said it because I
know they've got it wrong yeah yeah yeah
yeah when I pretended to hit him and he
actually flinched
she couldn't be laughing
nah wow you're actually scared yeah yeah
she's scared
that hizzy I'd have to smack her I'd
have to
just of sheer reaction
yeah you have to let her know that you
run this yard
he flinched oh I went to him and he
actually Flint no this is he yeah
that would take me out that would take
me out bro I could I couldn't be a
flying I won't see that no no no no no
no buzz around
I found out he had a girl so I gave so I
gave him a box of chocolate in front of
her and winked at her he smiled that's
all audacious a box of chocolates I
found out he had a girl so I gave him a
box of chocolates in front of her and I
also winked at her he smiled
where are we and who are you what's
going on what's going on in this
situation
probably
I don't know I'm assuming they're in
school it's like
you've met you've hit the nail on the
head because they can't be in public
yeah first of all why you just walk
around the Box chocolates yeah yeah
secondly how are you in a situation
where you're in front of my goal it has
to be a high school thing it's a high
school it has to be a high school team
thank you for clarifying that because I
was Bear confused yeah High School vows
we winked at her yeah winked to her like
that's my man now literally lit I just
stored off the chocolate there you go
and he's so smart
Define smile because he was like
yeah because I could be like yo yeah
yeah thanks why is this [__] giving you
chocolate winky in my face
ask her I haven't you saw it happening
oh stirred apart she wants exactly what
you've got what are you doing about it
and you're beefing me yeah this is why
hoes are giving me chocolate
do you not see the problem this isn't
this is why hoes are giving me
chocolates you are the problem yeah
because look look what just happened I'm
spending time with my my partner yeah I
certain time with my life partner some
dirty scatty [__] I just planted Dairy
on my lap and you're beefing me about it
she Winks in your face and you and
you'll win you'll be familiar you sat
there and just let it happen
yeah disrespectful yeah yeah you're a
joke you're a joke you're a joke bye
when I explained to the homies that I
was cheating on her for her own benefit
bro I'm banging her I'm cheating on her
because it's for her own good
she needs a thicker skin
she needs something because life will
teach you yeah yeah she's too middle
class I'm trying to teach her from yeah
she ain't lived through stuff and she
trusts everyone at naive
the naivety of this chick is unbearable
unbearable yeah she needs to experience
some suffering yeah and some heartbreak
this is the reason why I'm digging down
another chick every other week
yeah yeah and I'm leaving breadcrumbs I
need her to get her trailer yeah oh this
is how you find out if a man she is yeah
yeah yeah this is men of trash yeah this
is what she needs to learn yeah this is
for her not for me
when she sent me a good morning message
and I got irritated
we've all oh haven't we just there
haven't we just all been there male or
female when you're just getting a Miss
from the person you don't want to get a
message from good morning good morning
handsome good morning babe good morning
babes and you're so done with the
relationship oh just that move bro yeah
and stop and stop in that this is dread
in that scenario yeah she's never been
fatter do you know what I mean in your
head
do you actually know what I mean she's
never been far and uglier
than when you're over this little
situation that morning you start seeing
moles you've never seen before and she
message you good morning you open her
WhatsApp immediately like and you're
like what what am I thinking
don't who Do You Think You Are
pleasantries in the AM yeah who do you
act you're not my girl you're not you've
never been my girl
let me just clarify it now you've never
been here it was a facade
Jesus that's insane I got a couple more
come
when she caught me sniffing underwear
that wasn't even hers
God's sake bro when I realized my
daughter was older than the two guys I
was seeing
okay yeah that's
that's an issue that's an issue I uh
I had a DM the other day yeah a random
one in the requests yeah and there was a
t it was some some team trying to move
to me
and I was thinking
no offense I was thinking a little bit
old
um
and I saw on her page she had a
like a 21 year old son
and I was like oh yeah yeah
what does he expect from them yeah yeah
that's a bit and also
do you think I'm in that age right yeah
yeah do you think I mean admit to me
that you're a cougar first of all in
this initial breakthrough message admit
to me that you love younger younger
younger men because I'm not in this
review yeah yeah yeah we're not in the
same yeah same side I couldn't believe
that one I couldn't believe it
when I was sharing memes with my man
that my side had sent me
that
is treacherous that is treacherous on
both sides bro that's worse than that's
actually worse than cheating bro that's
so treacherous that's how
dare you I just received I received a
meme from my side and I'm kicking and
I'm like that's too funny and it relates
to my man yeah babe you need to say this
babe you have to see them tick tocks
tick tocks will be the worst for that
yes yes would be the worst for that oh
my God babes you've got to see this
isn't this so us there was
isn't this just so us
wow that's funny
nah that's uncalled for that's true yeah
don't you dare yeah anyway guys welcome
to the show Welcome to the party welcome
back guys welcome back thank you so much
for joining us today on this beautiful
Monday
um it's Vibes all around and guys you
already know the drill by now unless you
are new to the game please please please
if you enjoy the episodes if you want to
become indoctrinated into our cult
your daddies are here and the cult
babies are over on patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs it's gonna cost you
a very light three pound a month rabbit
like 10p a day you need to run the pita
SMG and enjoy all of the benefits over
there we've got over three years worth
of episodes over there we've got an
episode for you every single Thursday
which is uncensored uncut lots of funny
funds over there and as well guys we
have our incredible Community we
recently broke through 10 000 patrons
which is one of the biggest on the
planet I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
it's like first biggest on the planet
um for patreon so guys thank you so much
and then with that you will be invited
to join our flourishing Discord Channel
where all the Vibes are popping off guys
also killing it on the YouTube game
YouTube almost completed it we're on our
way we want to get a million by the end
of this year so please guys if you are
watching and you enjoy the content
subscribe to the channel if you are
listening on any of the podcast
applications please leave a lovely
review it means the world for us five
stars is awfully obviously preferable
but if you hate us and you need to
explain it do what you need to do okay
we hold no grudges here cold daddies are
very forgiving people all right without
any further Ado my boy has some stuff
about his favorite football team that he
wants to get off his chest I have no
idea what he's going to say so Fire Lord
freaks take to the mic and uh yeah well
man United's current form is what I want
to talk about obviously
you might all know I'm a average United
fan and I am pleased to say that this
has been the best season I've seen of us
in a very very long time and I am so
happy about it I can't lie it's like my
tone and my
um love for the club has gone up
dramatically since the start of the
Season remember beginning of the season
when I was talking about [__]
Brighton and Brentford tucking us into
104 nil yeah yeah that Brentford game
yeah yeah
and then the game after that was
Liverpool and we tucked him into one but
our current form is really really good
so obviously this comes out Monday but
we would have played um we played
Crystal Palace yesterday which was
Wednesday and we drew which I was very
annoyed about we played Crystal Palace
away and in my opinion playing Crystal
Palace away and playing probably Wolves
Away are like our two hardest games of
the Season we always tend to get like
it's a one-nil or like a shaky one yeah
yeah but like a shaky two one
um every season and it's always tough to
play there
um so when we play this when we played
them yesterday I was like we need to at
least back two goals we ended up drawing
one one which ruined our run of form
because
I think we had won seven games on the
bounce so we've not lost the game since
the Aston Villa game
um that we lost 3-1 when you know Emery
came
um but then I said obviously I said to
you um I think a few weeks ago that rash
would have just been banging it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fine
fine fine form
um and fun fact we are the only
um English Club that's left in or
eligible to get four trophies that's
left oh premier league is still legible
yeah and we're currently third
FA Cup carabao cup and we're in the
Europa League as well so we're the only
Premier League team that's still
eligible to grab hang and you could have
never said that two three years ago you
could never have said that yeah you
never have said that um Ericson hargen
is doing a fantastic job a fantastic job
with us
um he is the quickest manager on 145
years to win 20 games I believe swear at
United 145 he's the quickest manager to
reach 20 wins with United in all
competitions and I'm like this is its
first season yeah and like there's so
much more I can tell he can do with us
and and the squad and stuff so yeah I'm
very very happy but the main
I'm annoyed because I wish we beat
Crystal Palace because my vibe would
have been different right now we've been
very different at least it's not lost
though it's it's elite facts it's not
lost but the way we lost it okay wow oh
I swear wow right it was four minutes
extra time 91st minute free kick when I
say this free kick no one's saving it no
one's saving it swear wow what a free
kid I was so livid because whilst I was
watching I hate watching
um I hate watching games where we're one
nil up and you can just tell like any
minute now these men can score if you
don't do something about all your
whistle doesn't block I can't yeah I
can't sit through that my anxiety James
I feel like I'm on the pitch yeah and it
drives me insane yeah yeah so throughout
the whole thing I was like oh I'm just
living I'm just me and Toby just takes
it back and forth and I'm just like oh
my God oh my God let this game finish
let this game finish and then the 91st
minute happened also
annoyingly I'll get back to the main
point but also the annoying thing is
casimiro so he's our um Central um
midfielder right we got him from Real
Madrid
um very decorated he's won five
Champions Leagues he's won their title
many times so it was a great player to
have in our Squad he's been the like
rock of our of our Squad always helps
the rest of our Squad because he knows
what to anticipate so he's good
defensively and he's great offensively
so he's just a perfect package
but
um he was on four yellow cards
um and if you get five within a certain
amount of games I think it's 20 games
you miss the next game so he ended up
getting a yellow card against Crystal
Palace and the next game he plays
against Arsenal away and that's this
Sunday well by the time this comes out
this is yesterday so that's one thing if
we had beaten Crystal Palace and casino
didn't get a yellow card I would have
been like yeah we're talking in Arsenal
yeah but don't get me wrong I still
think we're gonna suck an Arsenal and if
we do
I'm just gonna say it now guys right if
we talk in Arsenal on Sunday which was
yesterday you're hearing it here first
final flag stinks United win the league
I've said it move on you reckon I think
United win the league
say less United are going to win the
league
if
Arsenal get tucked in yesterday
hopefully they did you're not gonna win
the league all right say less and we're
third at the moment all right come on
let me clarify the Points Austin 147
uh City I think on 39 and we're on 39. I
think Newcastle on 38 something like
that Newcastle City play today oh okay
say less um yeah they play today no
Tottenham and see you play today sorry
which would have been three three days
ago but yeah we'll see we'll see these
next few months are going to be very
juicy in football
very sounds I'm excited to hear about it
yeah I'm never gonna lie to you I'm
excited to everybody and I'm just happy
for the demise of Liverpool Liverpool
like 10th Chelsea are like ninth I don't
give a [__] about that yeah struggling
in fifth struggling I mean
yeah also I don't know if you remember
but at the beginning of this um Premier
League season which was in August I
think maybe at beginning of September
or late August I said to you I think
there are three teams that are going to
do very well and then if you remember I
said Newcastle I said Brighton and I
said Fulham yeah I do remember I
remember you saying it yeah all three of
them in a top ten right now gang
Newcastle are fourth Fulham a sixth and
say less love to see it yeah man but
yeah that was just a little insight of
what's going on mufc hopefully hopefully
hopefully
this was warranted and we tucked in
Arsenal yesterday so yeah we'll see Pang
uh all right gang
um random I am
Keen
to go to so UFC is coming to London in
March oh someone dm'd me or us about
that not too long ago yeah but I really
did that but this was this was after we
had spoken about the fight that we then
discussed that I said oh I'm gonna watch
it this time remember so after that
fight after that pod sorry someone sent
either me or us saying oh yeah they're
coming to the UK are you Mongolian
completely forgot about it but yeah so
I'm fairly certain I have to go okay I'm
fairly certain I have to go where is it
Anna who's on the card it's in the O2
okay
um and the main card is uh Kamara Usman
versus Leon Edwards round two okay we're
going fam Leon kicked his face
I looked at the yeah we're not doing
jump up yeah but I looked at the VIP
tickets the other day
minimum so it's a package deal okay okay
it's a package deal yeah this could have
been hoo-ha yeah but why I went on there
because I haven't got a sale yet they go
on sale on the 27th okay that's next I
need to set a calendar a reminder I'm
just gonna throw this out there
I don't expect anyone to give to gift me
the experience of this that I need so I
might have to pay for it
how much VIP is that like upper echelon
VIP or basic VIP there's bare different
videos there's three or four different
VIP packages okay
the first the cheapest one is like 1800
per person what do you get with that
that's a question
that's the minimum one so that's
preferred seating not cage side
preferred seat in
um like I call it like in venue dining
whatever the [__] that means it can't be
the Stalls it got me the hot dogs
somewhere it's probably they'll probably
a room dedicated yeah yeah yeah in
certain dining and like a couple other
things okay
but yeah I I just don't want to be doing
up gen Pop
um but yeah there's there's a couple
there's there's a couple things in there
at fam I looked at the price the other
ones it goes up to like I think the the
most expensive one was literally like
five grand that makes sense if it's the
person the first one is yeah something
like that and I was like well that's
obviously silly yeah
um but there's also I saw a hope there's
a hotel where is it I think it's at the
Continental okay
um
the Continental is next to the O2 I'm
pretty sure because I'm pretty sure when
me and ren went to O2 the other day did
we drive into the Continental car park
the other day it wasn't Continental on
it yeah so it's basically at the O2 okay
yeah I'm pretty sure you can get a
continental package which is like two
grand two in a bit per person but then
at least you get Hotel you get all the
[__] I just said and then plus you get
like a hotel okay okay okay so that's
the middle package no that's a separate
bag because they call that hotel
packages okay but even though it's the
VIP package plus the hotel okay okay um
so I was I looked at that one and I was
like you know what that is such an
outrageous price for me to go to this
thing but [__] it I'd actually do it
because I've never been to UFC before
I've never been and when am I going to
go to another one they're always in
America they hardly ever come to London
when is it in like UK March March okay
we've got time yeah that's the team yeah
yeah I'm not gonna Flex yeah but I'd
spend that money on boring [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah between how much I'm
gonna spend more than two grand on
[__] yeah Rags that's a fact right
it's probably petrol petrol of food yeah
right yeah I will spend that much yeah
so if I can put that into an amazing
night and if I get the hotel package it
means I can do stuff that night yeah
yeah I can go out after yeah I want it
because if I'm going to do it your boy's
gonna do it your boy's gonna do it yeah
yeah he's I want to find out where these
men are partying after I don't want to
go yeah facts so
um I'm putting it on the Pod right now
UFC uh [__]
London March we are going so yes we are
going that Usman uh Edwards rematch is
going to be lit I'm down I'm down don't
want to shoot on England yeah usman's
gonna tear him Lim from lim okay he's
got it's not gonna be a fight it's going
to be a punishment
okay I've got nothing against Leon
Edwards yeah yeah yeah but he doesn't
sound a chance okay in my opinion okay
I've got no input I'm just I don't even
and I don't even know who else is on the
card oh I was just about to start yeah
um I don't know actually let me check
who else is on the card so so far oh
just engage he's fighting as well we're
going
and Marvin Victoria's fighting say less
uh uh do I know anyone else on the card
I don't really know anyone else on the
card so main card is obviously Leon
Edwards Kamara Usman yeah
their records are actually very close
maybe Leon might do a thing he probably
won't but what's the records Leon's is
20 wins three losses and
um Kumaris is 20 wins two losses oh yeah
oh yeah never no and he's the current
Leon's the current champion he's a
current champion with the biggest upset
in like UFC history oh wow but the only
reason I'm scared for him is because
before he kicked his teeth out yeah he
was he was losing he was losing a
tactical window yeah it was found that's
the thing it was perfectly executed it
wasn't an accidental kid he clotted him
in his head yeah I saw it and put him
through the floor is um Francis still um
Champion or no France is that's a good
question I'm not actually sure kamara's
been taken out
um I decided is this one taken out yeah
crisis because I can't remember whatever
happened with this contract I'm pretty
sure he is still
considered a champion but he might not
be okay because I'm I can't remember
what the other guy the guy he fought
last time anyway I'm pretty sure Jon
Jones is coming back in Feb as well for
two you is it 285 Jon Jones Cyril gone
yeah okay so Cyril got I'm pretty sure
Cyril gone is the
current
Champion I don't know what's going on
with uh
on ganu I do not know but 5th of March
uh 3 A.M here so it'd be Saturday night
in America okay
um Farm Sunday UFC 285 okay
the return of John Bones Jones versus
Cyril gone Jon Jones's first heavyweight
fight um
oh is that is that just this is the
London one right no no oh no it could
never be oh listen oh okay okay listen
it could never be the London fight
that's a March as well yeah this is a
March as well okay UFC like when it's on
it's on it's on like a lot of weekends
okay okay but UFC two episode the one
we're going to is UFC 286. so the one
we're going to UFC 286 is obviously the
main event Leon versus kamaru the um
below that is Justin gaichi
um versus Raphael vasiv I've never seen
I don't think I've ever seen uh the say
a fight I don't think so Justin gate
he's a warrior so regardless it's gonna
be a fight okay it's gonna he loves to
scrap okay that's gonna be a fight
Marvin vittori if he's if he's if he's
here to to ramp mod Victoria could fight
okay so
um those three fights are going to be
banging I'm assuming the rest are going
to be hard as well but that one's going
to be banging on UFC 285 I as far as I'm
gonna wear I couldn't care less who else
is on the card apart from the main Jon
Jones yeah he hasn't fought in Years bro
I think you've mentioned that before
actually yeah and he's been he's been
he's been spending the last two three
years working his way back up to and not
back up working his way up to
heavyweight because he's the light
heavyweight champion okay undefeated
okay undefeated okay he is he's wider
regard as the best he has three you
actually fighter of all time okay Jon
Jones is no joke okay let me Google him
actually
um
a little bit of stinky trouble because
he beats his wife
he's a chronic drug user and alcoholic
and he beats his wife and he's outside
of the Ring bad guy throw it out there
and I'm pretty sure he's been done for
uh steroids as well outside of the Ring
I actually don't want to get it yeah
he's a bad guy he's a bad guy he's bad
guy he's not a good guy yeah inside the
ring
he's a god
outside of the Ring needs to go jail
yeah inside the ring he's a God okay him
and he's going up to heavyweight to
fight sirigan he was supposed to fight
Francis that was the fight that was the
[__] fight why is he not fighting for
us I don't know what France is a
contract saying I'm gonna have to look
into it because I'm speculating I'm sure
the comments will go crazy because this
is old news now okay and I just haven't
stayed up to date with it but anyway UFC
286 if you're coming you're going to see
your boys preferably in Professor yes
preferably away from you yeah just come
from the Continental downstairs into
prefer to eat in the years yeah you'll
see me all the way down so yeah I'm
really really looking forward to that
that's good we have to do it oh we're
going um come out on the twins I need to
set an alarm yeah in my phone right now
because I'm pretty sure yeah pre-order
comes out on the 27th of this month okay
cool uh right news flash gentlemen
Valentine's Day is almost here and by
the grace of cupid our friends at
manscaped are coming with their best
tools to get your boys downstairs says
ready for the special occasion come on
man we're skinning up I'd like to
propose making February 13th National
shave your Bulls day who's with me
yeah
get lucky this Valentine's Day and join
the 7 million men worldwide who trust
manscaped the leaders in below the waist
grooming with our exclusive offer
head on over to marscape.com and use the
code sng Sierra November golf for 20 off
and free shipping guys let's get back to
the episode thank you very much
9am by UFC tickets cool
remind yeah you're going to remind me oh
I'll get both I'm not telling you to log
in whilst I'm logging okay because the
servers will be busy
the servers were busy as it is I don't
need I don't need you in there with me
I'll just click quantity too
I genuinely don't need you in there all
right but all right cool but I'm excited
for it okay I'm excited for it it's so
interesting because these things there's
so many things in my life that will pop
up on my Instagram I'll pop up on stuff
and I'll be like oh that's so cool and
I'll just keep scrolling and I just
don't see myself like I've never been in
like a big events guy and you know how
you said you kind of inspired me
actually do you know when you said oh
you want you and tobes just want to do a
tour and just go around doing all the
stuff and I'm like why don't I do stuff
there's stuff that I like there is cool
stuff that I like
um and I just don't [__] do anything
and like so yeah when this popped up I
was like [__] this I'm going okay [__]
this and I think the only thing that
helps it is spending on the business
account puts a disconnect in my head
that I'm not spending real money you
know what I mean
what to watch a fight no no no I'm all
right
um but yeah we're gonna go there we're
gonna have a time your boy's gonna be
drunk and loud say less I can't wait for
that I'm gonna be Rowdy okay I'm done I
can't wait I'm ready
um oh yeah and also small enough small
announcement your boys gassed these men
already know about it but I'm going to
spread the word even though it hasn't
actually come yet so I could be chatting
[__] okay cool you already know what I'm
talking about but you don't yeah but
you're gonna find out
monster finally got in contact oh yeah
monster
the lovely one of the lovely ladies that
monster finally reached out yeah and
they're going to send you boys some
drinks guys it only took three and a
half years only only took three and a
half years of drinking monster every
single episode forever but your boy's
finally getting some free monsters
straight from Monster Round of Applause
I'm so gas
it's a long time coming that should have
been our first sponsor fam
anyway if they really want to help me
out they are actually the official
sponsor of the UFC so if they really
want to help me out
Circle it back yeah yeah yeah once
they're technically are the main spots
with UC so they really want to help me
out yeah yeah they can patent me
something yeah yeah I'm not asking for
anything but if you want to yeah you
know where to find me my DMs are open
facts um right so this is first week of
Our Last of Us recap fun fact I watch it
twice
fun fact I wish I watched it twice
because I forgot I'm a week behind you
man
oh yeah you did so I watched it on
Monday when it dropped and I watched it
uh so last week again cool so as we do
these guys for context we're going to be
a week behind yeah because this comes
out our episodes come out on Monday yes
and the thing comes out on Monday so by
the time this one drops this episode
episode two will be out already so yeah
we're talking about the previous one
yeah so you've got plenty of chances
technically you can't complain about
spoilers because you've got two weeks
facts buffer to sort your [__] out
that's cool we're gonna talk about it
yeah so you problem afterwards right
tell me your whole experience
bro so I completely forgot so when I saw
the first chick the daughter right I
thought she was the main chicks I
completely thought oh I'm sure there's a
gun in the thing but then I was like oh
it's actually not her okay but anyway
the whole thing was
it was mad because obviously the day
started off as on his birthday
was his birthday right he dipped out and
then the way she went to the um
to the neighbor's yard and then she went
she was looking for a book and then you
saw in the background you'll see that
old boy was a bag of spoiler reps by the
way premise
as you just bro she was grumping and
just twitching on the chair
in fact she was grumping in the chat on
the chair and the dog was not having it
the dog was staring at her breathing
tongue out everything I was like okay
say less and then
and then when she went back to the yard
and she saw those bloody tentacle type
things coming out of her mouth I've
never seen a zombie personified like
yeah bro you know what I mean terrified
wow that was terrifying wow that was
terrifying another terrifying bit was
when Mama was carrying his door and they
were dipping and then my man chased them
I've never seen science oh the bread
that leaped off the the salmon yeah
salmon dive off the cafe yes bro that
was terrifying I said I'm getting you by
any means yeah yeah yeah how he did that
holding his daughter he's a father he's
a man he's a man Jay he's a father and a
man because I'm dropping her
I would assume home was at my heels
you're weighing me down because all I
kept on thinking is if I'm in this
situation God forbid I hope it's my
nephew because he's light he's angry
yeah yeah you can pick him up you can
run for time yeah yeah but his daughter
was like what he was old as hell she was
a teenager yeah yeah a man jogged with
her oh brother strength that's a man
strength yeah
um
let's I can't I don't want to do this
but let's do this together but I can't
write say less so my favorites yeah not
my favorites but the things that
impacted me which they did so well they
managed to get me locked in in the first
scene with his flashback from the 1868
or whatever
blah blah blah the way they did that I
don't know how they did it but they had
me locked in locked in from a jump and I
was like oh yeah very interesting um and
then because it made it it made it so
specific that I'm like these men are
chat about real science this could
happen so I'm in
they somehow managed to get you
emotionally invested in this daughter so
when she dies I was ready to cry brother
the whole 15 minutes she was in it it
was a beautiful like transition of
emotions bro because like I said it
started off with his birthday she fixed
a watch for man she was gonna like
where's the cake blah blah blah I
promise I'm gonna get it for you
tomorrow I promise bro and then this
whole thing occurred bro what okay
in that scenario would you have logged
off Mrs Adler's head before he picked up
your daughter to get in the car
yeah come on watch it bro watch it bro
watch it Jesus
third floor
okay
cool okay
Jesus Christ yeah
so what was I say oh yeah I would have
rocked her drawers
I don't care how old she is
because I'm already in panic State and
my daughter's involved yeah she's like
get in the car though the acting in that
one sentence get in the car get in the
car get in the Car Fax I don't mean to
say anything else I don't mean to say
anything else in the car also when she
woke up in the middle of the night and
her dad was not there and there's bombs
going off yeah Green flashes she you
couldn't scare me like that as a
teenager
I'm not going outside yeah yeah I don't
care who's [__] I don't care if my
dog's at the door their dog's at the
door ah shoot
literally go home yeah yes bombs afloat
I don't know what's going on and my
dad's not here so yeah yeah you need to
be in safe terrible at 12 13. I'm not I
promise you I'm not waking up in the mid
at two o'clock two o'clock in the
morning yeah to helicopters and bombs
and my father's not in the house
my guardian's not in the house and
there's no explanation as to why yeah
facts facts at that time in the morning
terrified I promise you'll be terrified
I'm not going next door I'm not going
anywhere and then they're peeling off
and a plane crashes yeah the plane crash
was crazy crazy the way they depict this
is what I loved as well the way they
I've not even played the game I've never
played the game but you can tell it was
so the the direction and the the
cinematography of that car bit yep
gameplay it was so gameplay and you're
like wow this looks like a game perfect
bro the way they were doing the things
and oh it was amazing I loved that so
much very good
um and what I like about it is so fast
forward now to the way they're um like
living in these zones as well yeah
Boston they're in Boston Dave they've
managed to to perfectly skip all the
boring [__] from The Walking Dead so The
Walking Dead had two seasons of escaping
zombies and we had we had like a whole
season when no one's been bit no one's
even scared of zombies anymore before we
moved into like yeah these the new Mad
Max style civilizations The Last of Us
bro episode one boom straight yeah yeah
we're not even fussed about these
zombies
it's about how the how civilization
functions now yeah and then fam
the next bit when we move into home girl
with a bruised up face his new thing
moves our face I need to be a man who
strikes fear in other men the way that
my man was scared yeah bro she was like
but what about your guy he's gonna beat
he's gonna take one look at your face
and it's long for me it's gonna kill all
of us and she said don't worry about it
he answers he answers to me and he's
like I don't think you understand my
predicament yeah like your man's off his
head he's a man yeah he's a man I'm not
willing to deal with him he can't see
this so I don't know if I can even let
you out of here bro I don't know if I
can let you out because if he sees it
he's coming for me and I'm done I didn't
stand a chance I need to be that level
of man I need to be Joel yeah I need to
be a job yeah yeah I need to be job
because he's a man fun fact about him
before we move on to I already know what
you're gonna say and I'm excited for him
not excited for him gas for him oh um
yeah what's he Pedro Pascal yeah he's
he's been in he's never been writing
more than like less than nine point some
in IMDb yeah he's never been in a show
that's been less rated under like nine
under nine so
um Game of Thrones
um narcos obviously the last of us and
it was something else
I can't remember what the other one
something else yeah he's Beast he can
pick a script he can pick he can pick a
script he picks winners um is it the
Mandalorian he's the Mandalorian I've
seen it yeah no no no I haven't I've
seen that two episodes good bro you know
what you don't give a [__] about Star
Wars and the fact that you like it that
much I have to write it back good bro
I'll say this wow the mandalorian's good
say less yeah the only reason I stop you
know what's so jarring is that I I was
so late to it okay so was I thought yeah
I was so late to it by the because he
found baby Yoda like episode one or two
I can't remember he find a baby so by
the time I see baby Yoda I was so sick
of baby Yoda that was like I don't
believe I could buy into this [__] okay
okay because everyone's gas the baby
odor for the last year and now I'm only
experiencing for the first time I just
can't be Buffett okay
um but everyone said it's amazing it's
good so I need to give it another chance
I need to give it and um
is the main um foe or main villain in
Mandalorian I'll swear all right bro um
so yeah bro
is clearly banging
um there's so many what ifs what's gonna
happen next there's so many different
questions that needs answers bro there
is and did you see obviously not to flex
obviously at the premiere they did uh
what's coming up next do they have that
on the show as well yes they did
um and did you see the big thing yeah
but they showed that they show their
trailers as well oh really yeah yeah
okay cool that's another cool as well
because this is a perfect thing about
like game adaptations if these men are
doing a boss fights
these men are doing a boss fights in
there can't wait even deeper like that
yeah can't wait yeah I said it last week
and I'm glad everyone so far agrees it's
gonna be the number one show this year
um
probably uh dragon going back this year
I doubt it all right then it's gonna
bounce it it's going to be number one I
don't see it I'm doing it back to back
yeah I can't
um yeah I can't think of another show
that's coming out this year not that I
know that many shows this year but still
it is banging bro episode one yeah yeah
it is come on man
if you guys have not seen it make sure
you watch the last of us as we said
we're going to be doing a weekly
catch-ups and you've also got a week to
catch up on because we're a week behind
if that makes sense yeah yeah okay uh
right you've got trash news for us right
a woman is set to appear in court after
allegedly leaving her boyfriend to
suffocate in a suitcase during a game of
Hide and Seek
the incident took place after a couple
spent an evening drinking at their home
in Winter Park Florida in February 2020.
so was Florida come on in fact you did
say it's always Florida yeah facts the
Antics took a Sinister turn when a video
emerged of boyfriend Jorge inside of a
suitcase shouted I can't [__] breathe
an argument ensued and Andy accused
Sarah went to bed oh she woke up and
remembered she had locked him she locked
Jorge in a suitcase overnight he found
he was found unresponsive and later
declared dead
Sarah he was 42 at the time will now
appear in court on 30th of January for a
pre-trial hearing for his murder as he
did not survive the game
yeah that's it Matt
that's
she looks like she'd leave him in there
man said an argument ensued and accused
Sarah went to bed
and I said I can't [__] breathe get
me out the game's over I'm going to bed
you know what I actually don't need to
be spoken to like that
Jorge I'm going to yeah we'll deal with
this time you need this is perfect
because you actually need a timeout and
this is the perfect way to give your
time yeah yeah yeah yeah that's insane
you've got yourself in there you can get
yourself literally
I can't [__] breathe
that's the scariest thing I can think of
Gary yes
can think of suffocating in a briefcase
that's not even or a suitcase whatever
it was suitcase yeah I can't correspond
that
I can't correspond that
I said she went back to him and he was
unresponsive she woke up and remembered
she'd left him in there that that's a
level of fear yeah she'd run downstairs
you know when you say I can't remember
what we were just what we were talking
about but you said you know them ones
where you run and you have to you slide
because yeah yeah that's how you slip on
your side and just Scurry up that's how
you'd run downstairs oh my God I forgot
him in the suitcase no no no oh my you
wake up in fifth I don't think I'd make
it downstairs before I have like a rest
yeah yeah that's a level of fear I can't
take because just waking up late for
work oh you're exactly sends me in that
level of fear so leave my partner in a
suitcase to suffocate to death
I'm not going downstairs because I don't
want to see that yeah
because she actually ran into that
living room and just saw
the like yeah the bumps suitcase and she
said she'll be like oh my [__] God I
took this too she would have ripped it
open Rags flung it to find my man in
their dead
honestly
she's a prick for leaving him in there
but I do not wish that level of pain and
fear on anyone that is mad nurse
wow yeah bro yeah I would not wish that
on anyone wrong when I read that I
couldn't believe that when I first read
it bro
nah nah this looks Place yeah got him to
bed or they were drinking she must they
must have been they must have she must
have been off her face off a rocker
and he's off his Facebook even climbing
in there oh Rags also hide and seek
you're 43 and I'm 30. what are we doing
hide and seek let's do it what are we
actually doing no stop all of that also
Peng hiding spot
a suitcase he got in there called and
then zipped himself
oh he was gay I think he could have
moved yeah I promise you I would have I
could have said to the whole wave oh I
would have been trying to unzip it as
soon as because I can't even bring my
knees to my chest like that yeah so I
would have been that position for five
seconds I would have like no no no no no
no I'm not arguing with anyone let me
out please yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll be
screaming her name yeah yeah screaming
her name yeah it would have been a thing
where she probably would have been so
drunk that she probably sat on her or
something as a joke
what I can't hear you can I hear you sat
on it and he's like what's her name I
think it's Sarah Sarah I think it was
Sarah yeah he would have said some stuff
he can't take back yeah like you stupid
fat [__] get the [__] off me I'm dying
and she'll be like swear I'm going to
bed it's a game when you've actually
taken it too far you always do this and
I'm not entertaining anymore I'm going
to bed say hello say less bye
yeah that's vile that's the worst thing
I can think of yeah yeah yeah yeah cool
you've ruined the episode with that I
just want to let you know
play an event right Dilemma to finish
this off here yes sir come on finish me
off Daddy
pause
pause while you're looking I actually
don't think pause
counts if you're being intentionally sus
oh yeah I know I was just saying because
that's why I talked too long to say yes
because I knew I knew yeah like I won my
[__] in your mouth you know what I mean
don't there's no pause about it
I'm being very obtuse in my statement oh
geez
oh [__] that's hilarious also this is a
coincidence um that is your name so just
bear with all right updated James a
single dad with two kids for nine years
I've raised them since they were five
and six they're teens now I told his
daughter to do her chores
she said you shouldn't have you should
have had kids we're not your kids and
you're not his wife why are you here
James said nothing advice
bro bro
those are three sentences
teenagers say some vital [__] you should
have your own kids we're not your kids
and you're not his wife why are you here
why are you here James said nothing
James said oh
like that that's really rude she said
advice advice
to be fair like I've actually lived
through this okay as a kid Okay and like
it sucks but the facts of the are the
facts
if I'm not your blood don't chat to me
when I'm a teenager I got too much going
on inside yeah yeah bro I'm not
responsible for my responses I was ready
to rock my stepdad's draw every day of
the week
yeah okay I remember one time this is I
was I was young as well this is before I
was even a teenager okay I remember he
came upstairs one time obviously you're
a kid you're messing around at bedtime
me and my brother were rampant at
bedtime obviously his mom's job to come
upstairs and tell us to go to bed one
day this [__] comes upstairs and
he's like
didn't your mom say go back go to bed
I'm a vegan
who are you bro who are you this is my
yacht
get your bald blackhead downstairs send
my mum up
send my mama to tell me yeah yeah who
are you and I remember I literally was
like I swear I screwfaced him and I
remember word for word I remember like
it was yesterday because he was like
James you can stare at me like that all
you want
go to bed and I'm thinking
Shazam like maybe
I said go to bed
yeah yeah yeah yeah wow wow yeah yeah
I remember and you know why I remember
that so vividly was the fact that I knew
I couldn't do nothing about it at the
time and I remember when we started
listening to Childish Gambino okay
Childish Gambino might be in Freaks and
Geeks it might be something else he says
I'm rap stepfather you may not like me
but you will respect yeah yeah yeah yeah
as soon as I heard that childish life
yeah it might be Freaks and Geeks and I
remember thinking it's so fast you may
not like me but you will respect me
because I was seven-year-old thinking I
can't do [__] I can't do [__] who
knocking me out yeah unless you stab him
yeah
I'm watching bleed out on your bedroom
floor
you can't do it damn thing yeah and he
doesn't even love me so he'll top me up
he would have whack you you tell me how
he doesn't even love me so so he said
for my mom he'll give a [__] about me if
anything I'm a hindrance
so yeah
um he's staring at me all you won I said
girl I never wanted to snap my fingers
and turn 30. so far I bet bro wow it was
jarring but anyway so yeah a teenage
girl getting told to do chores Yeah by
someone doesn't matter who raised me
you're not my mom shut your mouth why
are you here why are you here yeah it's
outlandish wow that's a step tooth yeah
yeah all the other stuff is Peak but why
are you here why are you here you know
why I'm here don't don't listen to this
game I've been here I've been here your
dad loves me yeah yeah I know who he
loves get out
them and then teenage ages you ain't got
time for steps yeah in fact you actually
haven't got time for step parents
because I just want my family unit and
you're interrupting the whole thing
[__] up the whole base you're [__]
up the whole thing I just want my dad I
want my dad and my sibling
what advice Could you actually give her
though
doesn't doesn't
get cussed out by yourself
yeah I can't think of a thing there's
nothing you can do you just have to firm
it if you really love him you're going
to firm this abuse yeah yeah yeah I
think the only thing you can do I don't
know what she does she says she raised
him and suffer you have to start doing
[__] you have to do that stuff dude [__]
same thing with my stepdad I remember I
lost my bike one time he got my bike
back I think I told you before yeah yeah
yeah yeah someone stole my bike yeah he
got my bike back oh
stick around
we might need you stick around yeah
you're right
hilarious yeah so you you might have to
just go above and beyond yeah yeah and
start like yeah yeah just like part in
the sea for these Lots because otherwise
they will tell you to come out of Dad's
yard yeah they're not going to respect
you in one any way shape or form yeah
and a teenage girl doesn't want to see
her dad grips in anyone
Tina's God don't want to see her dad
grips in anyone
so yeah but homeboy didn't say nothing
he just said right you just sat there
and said
James said nothing to be fair you're not
her mum
do you be fair I'm not pointing fingers
but you're not her mom you be fair my
daughter's right yeah like my daughters
are right did she say anything wrong why
actually
you here why are you actually here oh he
was done by Iration he's so done with
that ratio yeah oh fast he's thinking I
don't know how to get out of this
relationship but if my kids just kick up
a fast eventually she's gonna yeah
you're asking me to pick sides and I'm
not willing to do it you know you're
yeah you have to go yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just know let's peek raw but anyway
that was good
um as always guys thank you very very
much uh we love you come and join us on
Thursday patreon.com gigs and as always
guys love love